attends je comprends pas de quoi tu veux
parler d'un tabou lequel un gros gros
tabou
les bouchons en plastique sur les
bouteilles de vin non non non enfin pire
tabou quoi les boîtes à pizza carré
alors que les pizzas sont rondes mais
non je sais les ouvertures facile qu'on
n'arrive jamais à ouvrir aux non non non
on connaît pas réglementé ou interdit la
prostitution a toujours existé mais dans
l'opinion publique et ben ouais c'est un
tabou de société voilà et dans la presse
c'est un sujet délicat à aborder la
presse française est éminemment
pudibonde chacun sait ça de peur de
faire rougir ses lecteurs elle ne
souffle mot de la question de la
prostitution légale et de la police des
moeurs
voilà en gros on en parle pour dire bien
qu'on n'en parle pas d'accord et pour
dire qu'on peut pas en parler nous voilà
mais il y a un nez il est vrai que cette
même presse ne se gênent points pour
exploiter le vise plus ou moins élégant
qu'il ya toujours une place à la
première page de ces journaux pour les
réclames défi aux côtés et qu'elle
consacre parfois des colonnes entières
très lucrative parce que je me suis
laissé dire aux petites annonces c'est à
dire à la prostitution plus ou moins
hypocrite des petites annonces mais il
n'y avait pas internet mais il y avait
déjà des annonces tout en finesse comme
notamment c'est drôle de leçon
d'équitation donné le soir le son
équitation miss d'alger 12 rue balzac de
deux à douze soir et la leçon équitation
madame go 2 à 7 6 rue godot de mauroy a
tué donc c'est un genre de code renonce
de courant à l'époque d'élever des
poneys dans des chambres de bonne la
prostitution sont toutes les formes avec
tous les vices et imaginables s'étale
partout dans les rues dans les music
halls dans les théâtres sur les
promenades même dans les petites
annonces de certains grands journaux
quotidiens qui hypocritement sous le mot
mariage publie pour de l'argent des
offres et des demandes d'amour puis il
ya gilles black qui va briser un peu ce
tabou en publiant régulièrement à partir
de 1890 des portraits dans différentes
villes de ce qu'ils appellent les
horizontales
ah les horizontales du coup c'est un
genre de guide du routard brooks d'une
finesse exquise
par exemple est-ce que tu as entendu
parler d'une certaine lucide et à nantes
elle a posé autrefois chez un peintre
renommé comme modèle pas de vertu
aujourd'hui elle est trop forte et ne
pourraient plus posé que j'ai une
furieuse de corser pour les essayer exki
n'est ce pas à toulouse il y à elisa les
railleurs l'appelle la planche juste
épithètes qu'elle doit à la longueur
remarquable de son buste et à la
maigreur extrême de son corps sympa
sinon à grenoble tu as la grosse m
remarquable par ses formes opulentes a
été très apprécié cet hiver une de ses
grandes qualités
la discrétion l'exagèrent au point de
cacher les fleurs dans les endroits les
plus mystérieux mastaing tabou
moyennement tabou quand même comme
aujourd'hui en fait avec elle chez vous
les fleurs et ben
[Musique]